In Eddie's family, there are lots of stories about his mom's aunt, Mary. Nobody wanted to cross her. She said what she felt, and did what she wanted. She'd open the Christmas present that you gave her and tell you right then, right to your face-- no, this is too small, this is inappropriate.
在埃迪的家族里，流传着许多关于他妈妈的姑妈玛丽的故事。没人想招惹她。她想说什么就说什么，想做什么就做什么。她会拆开你送给她的圣诞礼物，然后当面告诉你——不，这太小了，这不合适。
My parents claim that she would drive up and down the Garden State Parkway and take the azalea bushes off the side of the freeway, and take them home. Because she felt that they were free.
我父母声称，她会开着车在花园州大道上往返，把高速公路旁的杜鹃花丛挖出来带回家。因为她觉得这些花是免费的。
She said, "Oh, they're just growing on the road!"
她说：“哦，它们长在路边，又没人管！”
And we tried to explain to her, no, Aunt Mary, they're not growing, just growing there wild, you know-- someone planted them there. And then she would try to make excuses-- well, she only took a little piece of the plant, she didn't take the whole thing, there was plenty more there.
我们试图向她解释，不，玛丽姑妈，它们不是在那儿野蛮生长的，你知道的——是有人种在那里的。然后她会试图找借口——嗯，她只是拿了植物的一小部分，并没有连根拔起，那里还有很多呢。
There was the time she invited the family to dinner but didn't want to cook a chicken in the middle of a hot summer day. So, she cooked it in the morning, covered it with a piece of newspaper, and left it sitting in the attic. All day. Nobody wanted to take a bite, but you didn't argue with Aunt Mary.
有一次她邀请家人吃饭，但不想在炎热的夏日里烤鸡。于是，她在早上就烤好了，用一张报纸盖住，然后放在阁楼里。放了一整天。虽然没人想吃一口，但你又不能和玛丽姑妈争辩。
And then there was her laugh.
还有她的笑声。
Aunt Mary had a tremendous cackle. It really was like a sort of room-stopping sound that as a kid she always appeared to me like sort of the joker from the Batman TV show.
玛丽姑妈有一种惊人的咯咯笑声。那真是一种能让全场安静下来的声音，小时候我觉得她看起来就像电视剧《蝙蝠侠》里的那个小丑。
Here's Eddie's dad.
这是埃迪的爸爸。
That laugh was very strange, too.
那种笑声也很奇怪。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
So, a cross between The Riddler and The Wicked Witch of the West. But she wasn't necessarily trying to be funny. She would just say something crazy, and then you would laugh at her laughing. You weren't laughing at what she said, you're just laughing at her laughing because it was ridiculous.
所以，她是谜语人和西方坏女巫的结合体。但她未必是想搞笑。她只是会说一些疯狂的话，然后你会因为她自己在笑而跟着笑。你不是在笑她说的话，只是因为她笑起来的样子太荒谬了。
Because it would be a big--
因为那是一种很大声的……
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
--one of those kinds of laughs.
……那种类型的笑声。
Aunt Mary lived with her second husband, Uncle Vito, under one roof, but separately. They slept in separate beds, ate food from separate refrigerators.
玛丽姑妈和她的第二任丈夫维托叔叔住在同一个屋檐下，但生活是分开的。他们分床睡，吃来自不同冰箱里的食物。
Uncle Vito had a refrigerator of his own in the garage and Aunt Mary had her refrigerator in the kitchen.
维托叔叔在车库里有自己的冰箱，而玛丽姑妈在厨房里有她的冰箱。
And that came about how?
那是怎么演变成那样的呢？
I guess Aunt Mary did not really care for Uncle Vito's children, her stepchildren. And so she put a padlock on the refrigerator in their house, so as to keep Vito's children out of it. And so Uncle Vito decided that it would just be easier to keep his own set of food and drink in the garage. And beyond that, he I guess actually built his own sort of, like, Italian, manly palace in the garage, where he had a couch, and a television showing sports games, and, you know, a little rug. And that was his sanctuary.
我想玛丽姑妈不太喜欢维托叔叔的孩子们，也就是她的继子女。于是她在屋里的冰箱上装了挂锁，以防维托的孩子们去碰。维托叔叔觉得不如自己在车库里存自己的饮食更方便。除此之外，我猜他实际上还在车库里建造了一个属于他自己的、充满意大利男人味的宫殿，那里有沙发、放着体育节目的电视，还有一块小地毯。那是他的避难所。
And whenever we went there, whenever there was a spread on the table, we were always very nervous about which food would you take. Because it might be all out there together, but there would be always a back and forth about which food you should be selecting.
每当我们去那里时，只要桌上摆满了食物，我们总是很紧张该吃哪一样。因为食物可能都摆在一起，但关于你应该选哪种食物，总会有一番来回拉锯。
The two of them, they kind of would compete with each other. It was sort of like a little hosting duel. I remember that Aunt Mary would say to my father, "Hey, would you like a beer?" And you couldn't refuse Aunt Mary, so he would say, sure.
他们俩有点像是在相互竞争。这就像一场小小的待客决斗。我记得玛丽姑妈会对我父亲说：“嘿，你要喝杯啤酒吗？”你没法拒绝玛丽姑妈，所以他会说，好的。
Aunt Mary would offer you a beer. And Uncle Vito would look, and-- "Have one of my beers." And Uncle Vito would be, "I have some Miller in my refrigerator, in a bottle." And Aunt Mary would place this rusty beer can in front of you, with some store brand beer. And there was actual rust on the can.
玛丽姑妈会给你递上一杯啤酒。维托叔叔看到了，就会说：“喝我的一杯。”维托叔叔会说：“我冰箱里有美乐啤酒，还是瓶装的。”而玛丽姑妈则会把一罐生锈的啤酒放在你面前，还是某种杂牌的。罐子上真的有锈迹。
She'd give him a beer, and it would have rust on the top. And it was like a really old, cheap beer.
她会给他一瓶啤酒，瓶盖上都生锈了。那是一种非常廉价的过期啤酒。
I mean, let's just hold the story right there, and consider what is being said here. The way this family's story goes, she handed out beers so old that the can was rusted. And the story's been told so many times that that has basically become fact. But even though that is possible-- there were still some steel beer cans back in the seventies when all this takes place-- how likely is that? Is that really something to be believed?
我的意思是，咱们先把这个故事停在这儿，考虑一下这里所说的话。按照这个家族的故事说法，她递出的啤酒陈年久到罐子都生锈了。这个故事被讲了太多遍，以至于基本上成了事实。但尽管这是可能的——在七十年代这一切发生时确实还有一些钢制啤酒罐——但这有多大可能呢？这真的值得相信吗？
You know, I do. You know why? Because my mom describes her Aunt Mary's hygienic habits around her own home, in that she never used soap to wash dishes. Ever. She'd just rinse them. And she let her dog, you know, lick all the dishes. And the one time that my mother--
你知道，我信。你知道为什么吗？因为我妈妈描述过她玛丽姑妈在自己家里的卫生习惯，她从不用洗洁精洗碗。从来不用。她只是冲一冲。而且她让她的狗舔所有的碗。有一次我母亲……
Wait, wait, wait, wait. Again, I say-- now I know that that's the story that's told in your home and it's a family legend. But is that actually a believable story?
等等，等等，等等。我再说一遍——我现在知道这是你们家里流传的故事，是家族传说。但这真的可信吗？
Well, I think it is. Because my mother was so horrified one time at the prospect that the dishes weren't really washed with soap, that she went under the sink to find dish detergent. And when she did, she opened the container and started pouring it into the dishwasher, and rust came out. And so--
嗯，我觉得是的。因为我母亲有一次对餐具没用洗洁精清洗的可能性感到非常震惊，于是她到水槽下找洗洁精。当她找到时，她打开容器开始往洗碗机里倒，结果流出来的是锈水。所以……
Again!
又是这样！
I think there's a lot of rust.
我觉得那里有很多锈。
Again, I say that's a really great story that you guys tell each other. But first of all, detergent can't turn into rust, because detergent isn't actually metal.
我再说一遍，这是你们互相讲述的一个非常棒的故事。但首先，洗洁精不可能变成铁锈，因为洗洁精实际上不是金属。
Well, no-- I mean sure, there's probably some exaggeration. But there's so many Aunt Mary stories that are equally outrageous, if not more outrageous, that I can't help but believe that there is certainly more than a kernel of truth in these details.
好吧，不——我是说肯定有一些夸张的成分。但有太多同样离谱，甚至更离谱的玛丽姑妈的故事了，我忍不住相信这些细节中肯定不仅是一个真理内核那么简单。
And that, I guess, is exactly the point. It's hard not to exaggerate these stories. In any family, there are certain stories that get told over and over. And other stories that are never talked about. They explain who's who in the family, they keep the pecking order in order.
我想，这正是重点所在。这些故事很难不被夸大。在任何家庭中，总有一些故事被反复讲述。还有一些故事永远不会被提起。它们解释了家族里的谁是谁，它们维持着家族的等级制度。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today in our program, family legends. In our show, family members compare notes about stories that they've been kicking around for years, or have been completely suppressing, and try to figure out the truth behind the stories-- what really happened.
今天我们的节目主题是家族传奇。在节目中，家庭成员们一起核对多年来流传甚广，或者被彻底掩盖的故事，并试图弄清背后的真相——究竟发生了什么。
Act One, Take My Cheese, Please. In that act, we hear the greatest Aunt Mary story of all Aunt Mary stories.
第一幕，请拿走我的奶酪。在这一幕中，我们将听到玛丽姑妈所有故事中最伟大的一个。
Act Two, We Don't Talk About That. In that story, a guy tries to figure out a mystery that's nearly a century old about his own family.
第二幕，我们不谈那个。在这个故事中，一个人试图解开关于他自己家族近一个世纪前的谜团。
Act Three, Admissions. In that story, a mom, two daughters, and the worst acceptance letter in the history of college admissions.
第三幕，录取通知书。在这个故事里，一位母亲、两个女儿，以及大学录取史上最糟糕的录取通知信。
Act One.
第一幕。
So, let's pick up again with Eddie Schmidt and his mother and father. Eddie's sister, Lori, figures in the story at a key point.
那么，让我们继续埃迪·施密特和他的父母的故事。埃迪的妹妹洛丽在故事的关键点出现。
The setting-- the whole family, plus Eddie's Uncle John and Aunt Vivian, were at Aunt Mary's for a meal.
背景是——全家人，加上埃迪的约翰叔叔和薇薇安姑妈，都在玛丽姑妈家吃了一顿饭。
I remember, you know, Aunt Mary setting out the whole spread, and a lot of, you know, cold cuts and salami and pepperoni and cheeses. And I guess there were two different kinds of cheese from which you could choose. Somehow, Uncle Vito's cheese, the nicer cheese, provolone, had found its way onto the table. And maybe something that we didn't always get at home too often. But Aunt Mary was very insistent that we choose one kind of cheese, the American cheese.
我记得玛丽姑妈摆出了一桌丰盛的菜肴，有很多冷盘、意大利萨拉米香肠、意大利辣香肠和奶酪。我想当时有两种不同的奶酪可供选择。不知怎么的，维托叔叔的那种更好的波萝伏洛干酪出现在了桌子上。也许那是我们家里不常吃到的东西。但玛丽姑妈非常坚持让我们选其中一种，美国奶酪。
Lori was really wanting the different cheese. I think Uncle Vito had something that looked much more appealing to a little girl and she asked me if she could have it. As I went to reach for it, Aunt Mary did not want me to have that cheese. And she said, oh no, Lori should have this cheese. You know, this is good cheese, I bought this for her. And so she did not want to give her Uncle Vito's cheese.
洛丽真的很想吃另一种奶酪。我想维托叔叔的那种看起来对小女孩更有吸引力，她问我能不能吃。当我伸手去拿时，玛丽姑妈不想让我拿那个。她说，哦不，洛丽应该吃这种。这是好奶酪，我是专门给她买的。所以她不想把维托叔叔的奶酪给她。
And Lori, not being old enough to know that you don't cross Aunt Mary, was very insistent about having what she wanted, and she did make a little bit of a fuss. And so I said, oh no, Lori, this is the cheese, this is good cheese. This is the yellow cheese, this is the kind you like. Aunt Mary picked this out specially for you. And Lori got the cheese Aunt Mary wanted her to have. She did not get Uncle Vito's cheese.
洛丽年纪还小，不知道不能招惹玛丽姑妈，所以非常坚持要吃她想要的，还真闹了一点小别扭。所以我说，哦不，洛丽，这就是那种奶酪，这是好奶酪。这是黄色的奶酪，是你喜欢的。玛丽姑妈是专门为你选的。于是洛丽拿了玛丽姑妈想让她吃的奶酪。她没吃到维托叔叔的奶酪。
Uncle John and I thought it was ridiculous to have something put out on the table that someone couldn't have, so we passed a look. You know, we rolled our eyes a little bit to each other behind Aunt Mary's back, we thought. Thinking, oh my god, what an issue over something so ridiculous.
约翰叔叔和我认为把放在桌子上的东西却不让人吃很荒谬，所以我们交换了一个眼神。你知道，我们背着玛丽姑妈偷偷翻了个白眼。心想，天哪，为了这么荒谬的事情闹得这么大。
But that's all, it was just a look--
但这仅此而已，只是一个眼神。
That was it.
仅此而已。
Just a look.
只是一个眼神。
Now, do you remember this look that your Uncle John and your mom passed between them?
现在，你还记得你约翰叔叔和你妈妈交换的那个眼神吗？
I don't remember any shared glance. And my mom says that if there was, she can only think, in retrospect, that that's sort of the maximum gesture that they would have shared between each other. Because Aunt Mary was so, you know, owl-eyed. At the most, they had a split second sustained eye contact. That's it.
我不记得有什么眼神交流。我妈说如果真有的话，事后回想起来，那也只是他们之间最大的表示了。因为玛丽姑妈的眼睛像猫头鹰一样盯着人。充其量，他们只有一瞬间的对视。仅此而已。
And then after that, nothing else happens that day, no more fights, no more comment-- that's it?
在那之后，那天没再发生别的，没有争吵，没有评论——就那样结束了？
Nothing else happens. And we spend the afternoon and we return back home to Staten Island. That's it.
没再发生别的。我们度过了那个下午，然后回到了斯塔滕岛的家。就这样。
A few days after we had visited, Aunt Mary called up. And I thought that was unusual. Usually if we had seen her, we wouldn't hear from her again for a month or so. Anyway, she proceeded to tell me this whole story about this dream she had about Uncle John and I. She said we were laughing at her about the cheese. And this dream was reality to her, and she really thought we slapped her in the face by laughing at her. And we really had hurt her feelings. And she was very distraught and crying.
我们去过之后几天，玛丽姑妈打来了电话。我觉得这很不寻常。通常如果我们见过面，一两个月都不会有她的消息。总之，她开始跟我讲她关于约翰叔叔和我的一个梦。她说梦里我们因为奶酪的事情嘲笑她。对她来说，这个梦就是现实，她真的认为我们嘲笑她是往她脸上扇耳光。我们真的伤害了她的感情。她非常痛苦，还在哭。
I mean, I was flabbergasted. Because I wouldn't think I could hurt her feelings, you know, as a hard person, a tough person. When I knew she cried, that that's how much it upset her-- and I really felt terrible. So although we didn't feel we did anything wrong, I did apologize to her. And she seemed to accept it. And we never heard about it again.
天哪，我惊呆了。因为我觉得我不会伤害她的感情，她是一个强硬的人。当我得知她哭了，说明这件事让她有多难过——我真的感到非常内疚。所以尽管我们并不觉得做错了什么，我还是向她道歉了。她似乎接受了。此后我们再也没听过这件事了。
So a few years after this, Aunt Mary passes away and my family, my whole extended family, gets together for the reading of the will. And Aunt Marian is my mom's youngest sister, is actually the executor of the will. So she gets to read the will to everybody that's there. And to everyone's great surprise, Aunt Mary actually had $100,000 with which to will.
几年后，玛丽姑妈去世了，我的全家人，整个大家族都聚在一起宣读遗嘱。玛丽安姑妈是我妈妈最小的妹妹，实际上是遗嘱执行人。所以由她向大家宣读遗嘱。让所有人大吃一惊的是，玛丽姑妈竟然有10万美元的遗产可以分配。
Aunt Mary had been really cheap her whole life, and I guess would-- if you were there for a meal, she would rip a paper napkin in half and give you half to use as your napkin. And she would rinse her underwear out in the sink when on a trip. So she'd just have one pair of underwear she'd have for the whole trip. So no one could possibly imagine that she had all this money. But I guess from being so frugal, she had actually saved.
玛丽姑妈一生都很吝啬，我想——如果你去她家吃饭，她会把一张纸巾撕成两半给你用。出门旅行时，她会在水槽里洗内衣。这样她整个旅程只有一条内衣。所以没人能想象她竟然有这么多钱。但我想她是因为太过节俭，真的攒了下来。
I'm just biting my tongue here about that story-- about the underwear, about the actual truth of that story.
我正咬着舌头忍住不说关于那个内衣的故事，关于那个故事的真实性。
I don't know, my father maintains that he saw her washing her underwear out in the sink, so.
我不知道，我父亲坚持说他看到她在水槽里洗内衣，所以。
Well, sure. Sure, you're on a trip, like, sometimes you run out of underwear and you have to wash one out in the sink. But that's different than, you own one pair of underwear for a week long trip, and you just wash it out over and over because you're too cheap to buy more than one pair.
嗯，当然。当然，你在旅行时，有时内衣会用完，你不得不洗一件。但那和为了省钱不买多于一件的内衣，在长达一周的旅行中反复洗涤是不一样的。
Well, again. See, you would think that that's just kind of a crazy story. But then they said that after she died and they had to go through her things, they found cupboards full of underwear in plastic that she'd never touched.
嗯，再说一遍。你看，你会觉得那只是个疯狂的故事。但后来他们说，她去世后整理遗物时，发现柜子里塞满了从未拆封的包装完好的内衣。
Again, again-- cupboards full.
又是这样，又是塞满了。
All right. Packages, several packages.
好吧，总之，几包，几包。
OK, but anyway, your point stands. She was very cheap.
行，但不管怎样，你的观点站得住脚。她确实非常吝啬。
So she had actually amassed $100,000 with which to will. And she had ten nieces and nephews. And so $10,000 for each.
所以她确实攒下了10万美元作为遗嘱。她有十个侄子侄女。每人一万美元。
Marian started reading for us and started going down the list. Teddy and Johnny, those were two of my cousins, would be getting $10,000 apiece. Marian and Nick would be getting $10,000 apiece. And she went through the list, and when it came to Vivian and John and Dad and I, the money was not to be given to us. It would be set aside for our children in trust. We would not be allowed to touch it.
玛丽安开始为我们宣读名单。泰迪和约翰尼，那是我的两个堂兄弟，每人得到一万美元。玛丽安和尼克每人得到一万美元。她读完了名单，轮到薇薇安、约翰、爸爸和我时，钱并没有直接给我们要。而是存入信托基金留给我们的孩子。我们不允许动用这笔钱。
When we heard this, we were flabbergasted. We couldn't understand it. We argued with Marian, we were very angry, very embarrassed. And then we started-- after arguing and yelling-- then we started crying. I just couldn't understand. Why would Aunt Mary do that to me? I was the good niece. I was the only niece that went to visit Aunt Mary. And we knew that we had cousins who hadn't spoken to Aunt Mary in maybe ten years. So, you know, we kept saying, why everybody else? Why are we being singled out? What are we being punished for?
听到这里，我们惊呆了。我们无法理解。我们和玛丽安争论，我们非常愤怒，非常尴尬。然后我们开始——在争吵和尖叫之后——开始哭泣。我简直无法理解。为什么玛丽姑妈要这样对我？我是好侄女。我是唯一一个去看望玛丽姑妈的侄女。我们知道有堂兄弟姐妹可能十年没和玛丽姑妈说过话了。所以，你知道，我们一直问，为什么其他人都能拿到？为什么要单独针对我们？我们是做错了什么要受惩罚？
Only after going through the full gamut of emotions from embarrassment, to humiliation, to tears, to anger, were they even able to process and think-- could it really be the cheese? Could it really be? And then they had to think, well, there was nothing else.
只有在经历了从尴尬、屈辱、眼泪到愤怒的全套情绪后，他们才能理清思路去思考——难道真的是因为奶酪？真的会是那样吗？然后他们必须想，嗯，没有别的理由了。
It hadn't been that many years previous that the whole cheese incident came up. In probably my whole lifetime, that was the only time I remember making Aunt Mary cry. And so as John and I said, oh my god, it must have been the cheese. That's the only thing we ever did that really caused her to be upset with us.
那是几年前发生的奶酪事件了。在我整个人生中，那是我记得唯一一次让玛丽姑妈哭泣。所以正如约翰和我所说，天哪，一定是那个奶酪。那是我们唯一做过的真正让她难过的事情。
But the cheese. It just seems so crazy.
但是奶酪。这听起来太疯狂了。
Yeah, my read on it is that Aunt Mary-- who is really a tough cookie, a tough woman, who I think didn't really show her emotions-- I think because she had this crazy dream where she was humiliated and laughed at for not giving the good cheese to my sister, I think that it made her so vulnerable. I mean, my mom says it was the only time that she ever, ever heard her cry. And so I think Aunt Mary-- that that well of emotions came out. And I think she felt really angry that someone could make her question what she'd choose to do, and put her in that kind of position. That, I guess, she just never forgot that she had been exposed that way.
是啊，我的解读是，玛丽姑妈——她是一个非常坚强、强硬的女人，我觉得她其实不怎么表露情绪——我想是因为她做了那个疯狂的梦，梦到因为没把好奶酪给我妹妹而受到羞辱和嘲笑，我想这让她感到非常脆弱。我妈说这是她唯一一次听到她哭。所以我觉得玛丽姑妈——那份积压的情绪爆发了。我觉得她感到非常愤怒，有人竟然能让她质疑自己的选择，并将她置于那种境地。我想，她永远无法忘记自己以那样的方式被暴露出来。
You know, when you say it like that, actually, I feel like I actually kind of understand it. Like the dream that she had-- I mean, she was right. Your mom and your uncle, they were laughing at her. Actually, she was sensing something that was real. And of course it made her feel really, really bad.
你知道，当你这样说时，其实我觉得我有点明白了。就像她做的那个梦——我的意思是，她是对的。你妈妈和你的叔叔，他们确实在嘲笑她。实际上，她感觉到了一些真实存在的东西。当然这让她感到非常、非常难过。
Right. Well, and I think a different kind of person-- it might have been like, this small thing could have been a revelation where they changed the way they are. But I think for her, that was not going to happen.
对。嗯，我觉得换成另一种人——这件小事可能会成为一种启示，从而改变他们的处事方式。但我认为对于她来说，那是不可能的。
What's the role of this story in your family? Is this one of the ones that gets told over and over?
这个故事在你们家里起什么作用？这是被反复讲述的故事之一吗？
Yes. Yeah, this story, it's on the greatest hits. And actually at the time-- during the day, during the time that cheese happened at lunch-- nobody even thought about it afterwards. And the story was not shared at all. But it only really became this big story to share over and over again because Aunt Mary took it to heart. And, you know, paid everybody back. And, if anything, I think it probably makes all the sort of odd, funny things about her that we talked about earlier on become even bigger, as well.
是的。是的，这个故事是我们的保留节目。实际上当时——在那天，午餐时奶酪事件发生的时候——事后没人想过它。那个故事根本没被提起。只有在玛丽姑妈把这件事记在心上，并报复了每个人之后，它才真正成了反复讲述的大故事。如果说有什么影响的话，我觉得这让关于她的那些奇怪、有趣的事情变得更加夸张了。
Oh wow. You're saying because of the cheese and the will, that's what leads to all the other stories.
哇。你是说因为奶酪和遗嘱，才导致了所有其他的故事。
Well, yeah. It's almost like you're trying to sleuth out why it happened. So you start going back to the beginning-- going, oh OK, well she was always eccentric. And we were always intimidated by her. And then there are probably other funny family stories. But the Aunt Mary stories take on this whole life of their own.
嗯，是的。就像你在试图侦破为什么会发生这种事。所以你开始追溯到源头——觉得，哦，好的，她一直都很古怪。而且我们一直被她吓到。然后可能还有其他有趣的家族故事。但玛丽姑妈的故事有了属于它们自己的生命。
What's so interesting is that if, in fact, she was doing this as an act of spite and to get the last word, it's so misplaced. Because of course you don't get the last word. The living absolutely get the last word in every possible way.
最有趣的是，如果实际上她是出于恶意并想获得最后发言权而这样做，那真是大错特错了。因为当然你得不到最后发言权。活着的人在所有可能的方式上绝对拥有最后发言权。
Right, although you do get lionized with some amusing qualities.
对，虽然你被赋予了一些有趣的品质。
This is what I'm talking about. You start with one $10,000 bequest, and before you know it, people are saying that you only owned one pair of underwear.
这就是我所说的。从1万美元的遗赠开始，不知不觉中，人们就开始说你只有一条内衣了。
Right. We get the last word, but there can be no rebuttal.
对。我们得到了最后的发言权，但她已经无法反驳了。
Eddie Schmidt, and his mother and father, Josie and Bob Schmidt.
埃迪·施密特，以及他的父母，乔西和鲍勃·施密特。
[MUSIC - "Now Mary" by The White Stripes]
[音乐 - 白条乐队的《现在玛丽》]
Act Two. We Don't Talk About That.
第二幕。我们不谈那个。
Some family stories are notable mostly because of their absence. That they're too disturbing or too scandalous for anyone to ever acknowledge.
有些家族故事之所以引人注目，主要是因为它们的缺失。它们太令人不安或太丢人，以至于没人愿意承认。
Kevin O'Leary's family specializes in stories like that.
凯文·奥利里的家族专门讲述这类故事。
My great grandfather had this Edison Amberola A-1 phonograph player. Its cabinet is made of carved mahogany and a brass crank sticks out from the right side. Inside there are four drawers, each holding 25 Edison Gold Moulded recordings. The recordings are tubular wax cylinders, about the size of an empty roll of toilet paper. Each one has a cardboard sleeve with a picture of Thomas A. Edison on its side.
我的曾祖父有一台爱迪生Amberola A-1留声机。它的柜子是用雕花红木做的，右侧伸出一个黄铜曲柄。里面有四个抽屉，每个抽屉装着25张爱迪生金模唱片。唱片是管状蜡筒，大约像空的卫生纸卷那么大。每个唱片都有一个纸套，侧面印着托马斯·爱迪生的照片。
Here's how it works. You open the door, pull out a drawer, take a wax cylinder from its sleeve, insert it horizontally onto the player, turn the crank a little bit, and place the needle on the spinning cylinder.
它是这样工作的。你打开门，拉出一个抽屉，从套子里取出一个蜡筒，把它水平插入播放器，转动一下曲柄，然后把唱针放在旋转的圆筒上。
[MUSIC]
[音乐]
For three decades this Edison sat in my grandparents house in Iowa, which is where I first saw it. I used to ask about it all the time, but no one would ever play it. It initially belonged to my great-grandfather, my grandfather's dad, who bought it in 1911. He was 28-years-old at the time and he and his young wife, my great-grandmother, lived in Council Bluffs. It was exactly the kind of thing a well-to-do family would have in those days-- a little like having a Steinway in the living room.
三十年来，这台爱迪生留声机一直放在我祖父母在爱荷华州的家里，那也是我第一次见到它的地方。我过去经常问起它，但没人会播放它。它最初属于我的曾祖父，也就是我祖父的父亲，他在1911年买下了它。他当时28岁，他和年轻的妻子，也就是我的曾祖母，住在康瑟尔布拉夫斯。在那个年代，这正是那种富裕家庭会拥有的东西——有点像在客厅里放一台施坦威钢琴。
The same year my great-grandfather bought the phonograph, my great-grandmother gave birth to their only child, my grandfather. I know this now, but I didn't before, growing up. Whenever I would ask about the Edison or my great-grandfather, or any related history, all I got were shrugs and silence.
曾祖父买留声机的那一年，曾祖母生下了他们唯一的孩子，也就是我的祖父。我现在知道了，但在成长过程中我并不清楚。每当我问起这台爱迪生留声机或曾祖父，或者任何相关的历史时，我得到的只是耸耸肩和沉默。
My grandfather would never discuss his parents, so his kids-- my mom and my uncles Jim and John-- literally had no idea who their dad's dad was. They didn't know where he was born, or what he did for a living, or what he looked like, or even his name.
我祖父从不讨论他的父母，所以他的孩子们——我妈妈和我的叔叔吉姆和约翰——完全不知道他们父亲的父亲是谁。他们不知道他在哪里出生，靠什么谋生，长什么样，甚至连他的名字都不知道。
I have no knowledge of him at all. Any more than I think my brothers do.
我对他就一无所知。我觉得我的兄弟们也一样。
Nobody ever talked about him, nobody ever said anything about him, and nobody ever showed us any pictures about him.
没人谈论过他，没人说过关于他的任何事，也没人给我们看过任何关于他的照片。
If the man was to walk into this room right now, I'd never know who he was.
如果那个人现在走进这个房间，我永远不会知道他是谁。
Evidently there was something that wasn't either on the up and up, or done like it was supposed to. Or somebody in-married or whatever the problem might have been-- happened. And so from that point on, it was just-- shut up, not to talk about, not said anything about. Never, as far as I can remember.
显然有什么事情要么是不正当的，要么是没按规矩办的。或者是家里有人内部联姻之类的麻烦——发生了。所以从那时起，就变成了——闭嘴，不要谈论，不要说任何关于他的话。据我记忆所及，从来没有。
What's weird about this is that John B. Keeline I, my great-grandfather, wasn't some small town nobody. He was one of the most prominent men in Council Bluffs. He was rich. Very, very rich. His parents and grandparents had been directors and heavy shareholders in the Council Bluffs savings bank, and amassed a small fortune they'd inherited at 21. I found his probate papers. They're dated from 1888 to 1904. Besides the astonishing amount of bank stock and dividends listed, he also owned two thirds interest in a Wyoming territory cattle ranch and thousands of head of cattle, acres and acres of land in Council Bluffs, and about $200,000 in cash, which today equals about $3 million.
奇怪的是，我曾祖父约翰·B·基林一世并不是什么小城镇的无名小卒。他是康瑟尔布拉夫斯最显赫的人物之一。他很有钱。非常、非常有钱。他的父母和祖父母曾是康瑟尔布拉夫斯储蓄银行的董事和重要股东，积累了一笔他在21岁时继承的小额财富。我找到了他的遗嘱认证文件。日期从1888年到1904年。除了列出的惊人数量的银行股票和股息外，他还拥有怀俄明领地一家牛场的三分之二股份和数千头牛，在康瑟尔布拉夫斯拥有大片大片的土地，还有约20万美元的现金，相当于今天的300万美元左右。
He sounds like the kind of guy who would have generated some conversation within the family. But it wasn't until eight years ago, when my grandfather died and our family gathered in Iowa for the funeral, that I began to piece together the mysterious story of John B. Keeline.
他听起来像是那种会在家族内部引发一些话题的人。直到八年前，当我祖父去世，我们全家聚在爱荷华州参加葬礼时，我才开始拼凑出约翰·B·基林这个神秘的故事。
It was after my grandfather's burial, and a guy from the cemetery led us on a tour to see some of our family grave sites. We were walking behind him when he stopped and pointed to a small headstone, about the size of a house brick and covered in oak leaves.
那是我祖父安葬后，公墓的一个人带我们去参观我们家族的一些墓地。我们跟在他身后时，他停下脚步，指着一块小墓碑，大约像砖块大小，覆盖着橡树叶。
The caretaker took a deep breath, and you could tell he was about to say something. But he never got the chance. My grandmother was all over him. "That is not a member of the Keeline family!" she snapped. "You don't know what you're talking about, just move along, young man."
管理员深吸了一口气，你能看出他正要说些什么。但他没机会了。我祖母冲向了他。“那不是基林家族的成员！”她厉声说道。“你不知道自己在说什么，年轻人，走开。”
A word about my grandmother, who's now dead. She was a tiny woman, just over five feet tall, who wore a tremendous amount of jewelry. And she also had a way of scaring the bejeezus out of just about anyone. Imagine a tiny, old, white lady, with the temper and fashion sense of Mr. T, and you get the idea.
关于我祖母，她现在已经去世了。她是一个娇小的女人，身高刚过五英尺，戴着大量的珠宝。而且她有一种吓跑任何人的本事。想象一个娇小的、苍老的、白人老太太，有着T先生的脾气和时尚感，你大概就能明白我的意思了。
So nana had control of the tour from there. We kept moving, walked up a hill which overlooks the rest of the cemetery, to my great-grandfather's grave. He has a modest stone, about the size of the yellow pages, resting in the grass. He died in 1926. John Beresheim Keeline. My great-grandmother's stone lies to the right of his, Margaret C. Keeline. She died in 1913.
所以从那时起，祖母控制了参观。我们继续前进，走上了一个俯瞰公墓其余部分的山坡，来到了曾祖父的墓前。他有一块朴素的石头，大约像黄页电话簿那么大，静静地躺在草地上。他死于1926年。约翰·贝雷斯海姆·基林。曾祖母的墓碑在他右侧，玛格丽特·C·基林。她死于1913年。
This was the first time anyone in my family had ever acknowledged the existence of these two people. I wondered why their lives were so short. She was only 27 when she died, and he was only 43. More than anything, though, I wondered why my grandmother flipped out on the poor fellow from the cemetery. I memorized the dates on their headstones, and on the way back to the hotel I had my father drop me off at the local library.
这是我家里第一次有人承认这两个人的存在。我纳闷为什么他们的生命如此短暂。她去世时只有27岁，他只有43岁。然而最让我好奇的是，为什么我祖母会对公墓那个可怜的家伙发飙。我记住了墓碑上的日期，在回酒店的路上，我让父亲把我送到当地图书馆。
I found the microfilm for the local paper, the Council Bluffs Nonpareil. I scroll through until I reach the edition published on the same date as the one carved into my great-grandfather's headstone. November 15, 1926. The headline ran across the entire page, in big bold letters. John B. Keeline Kills His Wife And Himself. There are a few sub-headlines, also in big bold letters. Poultry Raiser And Ex-bank Official Also Wounds Sister-in-Law When He Runs Amok At Home With Shotgun. And another one: Turns Home Into Shambles After Protracted Drinking; He Dies Instantly, Spouse Lives Short Time. And the final one, She Planned To Get A Divorce, Friends Say.
我找到了当地报纸《康瑟尔布拉夫斯非凡报》的缩微胶卷。我一直滚动直到找到出版日期与曾祖父墓碑上镌刻的日期相同的那一期。1926年11月15日。标题横跨整个页面，用大字号加粗字体写着：约翰·B·基林杀妻自尽。下面还有几个副标题，也是大字号加粗：家禽饲养员兼前银行官员在家中用猎枪狂乱杀人，还误伤了嫂子。另一个是：酗酒后将家变成屠场；他当场死亡，配偶短时间后离世。最后一个是：朋友们说她曾计划离婚。
I was immediately self-conscious about someone in the library walking by and seeing the gruesome headlines on my screen. I made some copies and headed to the bar across the street from the library, ordered a Budweiser, and read the story again. It's pretty graphic. Council Bluffs, Iowa, Monday evening, November 15, 1926.
我立刻意识到图书馆里有人走过，看到屏幕上那骇人的标题，感到很局促。我复印了几份，去了图书馆街对面的酒吧，点了一杯百威啤酒，又读了一遍这篇报道。内容非常生动。爱荷华州康瑟尔布拉夫斯，1926年11月15日，星期一晚上。
John B. Keeline, 43, sportsman and chicken farm owner, shortly after nine Monday morning shot and killed his wife, Carla, 26, wounded his sister-in-law, Mrs. Henry Andreason, and blew out his brains.
约翰·B·基林，43岁，运动员兼养鸡场主，周一上午九点多一点，枪杀了他的妻子卡拉，26岁，打伤了他的嫂子亨利·安德烈森夫人，随后朝自己的脑袋开枪自杀。
Quarrels over a threatened divorce and the supposed refusal of Mrs. Keeline to place a second mortgage on their home, which had been deeded to her, are believed to have precipitated the killings.
据信，关于威胁离婚的争吵，以及基林夫人拒绝在他们那栋名义上已过户给她名下的房子上办理二次抵押贷款，促成了这场杀戮。
The immediate cause of the shootings is said to have been Mrs. Keeline's desire to leave her husband and go with her sister to Gary, Indiana to live.
枪击事件的直接诱因据说是基林夫人希望离开丈夫，和她的姐姐一起去印第安纳州的加里生活。
Members of Mrs. Keeline's family say that such quarrels have been frequent during the last month and that Keeline had been under the influence of whiskey and on the verge of delirium tremens for weeks.
基林夫人的家人们说，过去一个月这种争吵很频繁，而且基林几周来一直受到威士忌的影响，处于震颤性谵妄的边缘。
Sheriff P.A. Lainson, Coroner H. Cutler, and County Attorney Frank F. Northrop have been reconstructing the crime from the evidence of bullet-scarred walls, blood patches, and other signs at the Keeline home, 201 Frank Street.
警长P.A.莱森、验尸官H.卡特勒和县检察官弗兰克·F·诺斯罗普一直在根据201弗兰克街基林家墙上弹痕、血迹和其他迹象来重现犯罪现场。
Their reconstruction of the crime disclosed that Keeline attacked his wife while she was preparing to dress in their bedroom. Brandishing a loaded 16-gauge shotgun, he advanced upon her as she cowered, totally nude, in the door of a clothes closet with her hand over face in an attempt to ward off the shot, which a second later went crashing through her hand and into her left jaw and neck.
他们对犯罪过程的重构揭示了，基林在妻子准备穿衣时袭击了她。他挥舞着一把装填好子弹的16口径猎枪，向蜷缩在衣柜门口赤身裸体的妻子步步紧逼，她用手捂住脸试图挡住枪口，一秒钟后，子弹穿过她的手击中了她的左下颌和脖子。
Mrs. Andreason was attracted from her own bedroom where her child Gloria, six-months-old, lay asleep. Taking one terrified look into the bedroom, Mrs. Andreason is believed to have noticed the nude body of Mrs. Keeline, writhing in a pool of blood at the half-open closet door, then ran to the stairs, intending to summon aid.
安德烈森夫人被惊动，从她自己的卧室里跑出来，她六个月大的孩子格洛丽亚正在熟睡。安德烈森夫人恐惧地向卧室看了一眼，据信她注意到了赤身裸体的基林夫人，在半掩的衣柜门边血泊中挣扎，随后她跑向楼梯，打算去求救。
Before she had descended three steps, she was met with the other charge from the shotgun in the hands of Keeline, and staggered the remainder of the distance downstairs, with part of her left shoulder torn away.
在她还没下三级台阶之前，基林手中的猎枪的另一发子弹就击中了她，她踉踉跄跄地下了剩下的楼梯，左肩被撕裂了一部分。
Keeline then went downstairs, placed the empty shotgun on a chair, went into the butler's pantry, leveled the 20 caliber special police pistol at his head, pulled the trigger, and fell over a chair.
随后，基林走下楼，把空猎枪放在椅子上，走进管家储藏室，用20口径警用手枪对着自己的头扣动了扳机，倒在椅子上。
Mrs. Andreason, mother of the dead woman and mother-in-law of Mrs. Henry Andreason, said her daughter had talked of her troubles for several days.
死者的母亲、亨利·安德烈森夫人的婆婆安德烈森夫人说，她的女儿已经谈论她的烦恼好几天了。
Sunday night, during a visit to her mother, Mrs. Keeline is quoted by members of the family as saying, "I'm afraid of John. He insists on keeping a loaded gun where he can reach it and he has threatened me. Once I hid it, but he made me search it out and give it back to him. He is drinking all the time and I'm afraid he will do something to me." The mother advised her daughter as best she was able.
周日晚上，在看望她母亲期间，据家人引述，基林夫人说：“我害怕约翰。他坚持要把上膛的枪放在他能拿到的地方，他威胁过我。有一次我把它藏了起来，但他逼我把它找出来还给他。他一直在喝酒，我怕他会对我做什么。”母亲尽其所能给女儿提出了建议。
Keeline is said to have been admitted to an Omaha hospital less than six months ago, suffering from the effects of excessive drinking. He lay between life and death for days, hope being given up on several occasions, until they finally rallied and returned to his home.
据说基林不到六个月前曾被送往奥马哈的一家医院，患有酗酒导致的疾病。他在生死边缘徘徊了数天，曾多次被认为无望，直到最后恢复过来回到家中。
After being nursed through a period of convalescence, which followed this outbreak of what is described by Mrs. Andreason as delirium tremens, Keeline began drinking again, and abusing the wife who had nursed him. His condition gradually becoming worse, until it ended in Monday's bloody tragedy.
在度过了一段康复期后，紧随安德烈森夫人所描述的震颤性谵妄爆发，基林又开始酗酒，并虐待照顾他的妻子。他的病情逐渐恶化，直到最后以周一那场血腥的悲剧收场。
Mrs. Carla Keeline was the third wife of John B. Keeline. The first wife was Miss Margaret Coyle, member of a prominent Council Bluffs family, who died in a local hospital following treatment for injuries she is said to have received when she fell over a chair in a scuffle with her husband while he was suffering from the effects of drink.
卡拉·基林夫人是约翰·B·基林的第三任妻子。第一任妻子是玛格丽特·科伊尔小姐，康瑟尔布拉夫斯显赫家族的一员，她在当地一家医院接受治疗后去世，据说是因为她在丈夫酒后闹事时摔倒在椅子上受了伤。
Miss Margaret Coyle, she's my great-grandmother, the one buried next to him. Later I found her death certificate. It says she died of Septicemia after 28 days in the hospital. A newspaper article announcing her death in 1913 says nothing about how she was injured.
玛格丽特·科伊尔小姐，她是我的曾祖母，葬在他旁边的那个。后来我找到了她的死亡证明。上面写着她在医院住了28天后死于败血症。一篇1913年宣布她去世的报纸文章对她是如何受伤只字未提。
The death of Mrs. Keeline number one left Johnny Keeline, then two-years-old, motherless.
第一任基林夫人的去世让当时年仅两岁的约翰尼·基林失去了母亲。
Johnny Keeline. That's my grandfather, who we all called Papou.
约翰尼·基林。那是我的祖父，我们都叫他Papou。
A few years later, Keeline married Miss Zelma E. Shellenberg, at that time an employee of the Beno store in the city. Four years ago, wife number two obtained a divorce from Keeline. Mrs. Keeline number two is alleged to have brought her charges after coming home unexpectedly from a trip to the Pacific coast and surprising Keeline with two other local men and three women, engaged in a drunken orgy at the Keeline home.
几年后，基林娶了塞尔玛·E·谢伦伯格小姐，当时她是城里Beno商店的一名员工。四年前，第二任妻子与基林离婚。据称，第二任基林夫人是在太平洋海岸旅行突然回家，发现基林与另外两名当地男子和三名妇女在家中举行酒后狂欢后提出了指控。
Mrs. Keeline number three, killed Monday in the mad attack which turned the old Keeline homestead into a shambles, was married to John B. Keeline two years ago, at which time she worked at the Wilcox flower store. The girl was well known locally.
第三任基林夫人，也就是周一在那场让旧基林宅邸变成屠场的疯狂袭击中被杀的那位，两年前嫁给了约翰·B·基林，当时她在威尔科克斯花店工作。那个女孩在当地很有名。
So his third wife's, Carla's, was the small headstone the guy in the cemetery was trying to point out. I went to see it later. All it said was Carla, 1902 to 1926. There's no last name.
所以他的第三任妻子卡拉的墓碑，就是公墓那个人试图指出的那块小墓碑。我后来去看过。上面只写着卡拉，1902到1926年。没有姓氏。
At the hotel later that night, after everyone's kids were asleep, I gathered the rest of my family into my uncle's room and read out loud what I had found to them. The news I was telling them, in brief, was this-- my great-grandfather the man who was your grandfather, was married three times. He beat his first wife to death in a drunken rage-- that was your grandmother. He was never punished. His second wife, after years of abuse, divorced him. And his third wife he shot in the face before killing himself.
那天晚上晚些时候，在酒店里，等所有孩子都睡着后，我把家里其他人聚到我叔叔的房间里，大声读出我发现的一切给他们听。简而言之，我告诉他们的消息是——我的曾祖父，也就是你们的祖父，结过三次婚。他醉酒后暴打并杀害了他的第一任妻子——那是你们的祖母。他从未受到惩罚。他的第二任妻子在遭受多年虐待后与他离婚。而他的第三任妻子，他在自杀前朝她的脸上开了一枪。
When I finished reading there was a long silence. Someone said, "Well, there's the big family secret." And that was about it.
当我读完时，陷入了长久的沉默。有人说：“好吧，这就是那个家族大秘密。”就这样。
Then a bunch of us piled into a hotel van and went to a new floating casino on the bank of the river between Council Bluffs and Omaha. No one mentioned the article again, and no one ever asked me for a copy.
然后我们一群人挤进酒店货车，去了康瑟尔布拉夫斯和奥马哈之间河岸上的一个浮动赌场。没人再提那篇文章，也没人向我要过副本。
I suppose I kind of forgot the whole thing, too, for a while. And then last year, the Edison, which I inherited, arrived at my apartment. The first day I got it was the first time I ever heard it played. It sounded so beautiful, so old. But creepy, too.
我想有一段时间我也差不多把这事忘了。直到去年，我继承的那台爱迪生留声机到了我的公寓。我得到它的第一天，是我第一次听到它演奏。听起来太美妙了，太古老了。但也毛骨悚然。
The more I thought about it, the more I was convinced that my great-grandfather's story had to mean something in my family. It had to have affected us in some way. It didn't seem possible that we had all just forgotten it, that the brutal facts of his life had just floated away as soon as I told him in the hotel room that night.
我想得越多，就越确信曾祖父的故事在我的家族中肯定意味着什么。它一定以某种方式影响了我们。似乎不可能我们所有人就这样把它忘了，不可能那些残酷的生活事实在我那天晚上在酒店房间告诉他们后，就随着烟消云散了。
I decided to ask my mom and uncles about it. I went to Iowa to see Uncle Jim. He's the youngest of my mom's family and we've always been pretty close. He started out, like all the kids, saying that he really hadn't given the whole thing much thought. But after awhile, he opened up. And then he told me something I was totally unprepared for. That his father taken him aside 40 years ago, when he was in his early 20's, and confided in him.
我决定问问我妈妈和叔叔们。我去了爱荷华州看吉姆叔叔。他是妈妈家里最小的，我们一直很亲近。他一开始像所有孩子一样，说他其实没怎么考虑过这件事。但过了一会儿，他敞开心扉了。然后他告诉我一件我完全没有准备好的事。那就是他的父亲四十年前，在他二十出头的时候，曾私下告诉过他。
It was at the Central [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Savings Bank, where at that time I worked, and at that time he owned. And he had told me of the problems.
那是在中央储蓄银行，当时我在那工作，而他拥有那家银行。他告诉我关于他的问题。
What did he tell you?
他告诉你什么了？
Well, he told me that his father was an alcoholic. That he was a vicious person. cruel person, I guess, is maybe a better way to put it. Had killed, or was involved in killing his mother.
嗯，他告诉我说他父亲是个酗酒者。是个恶毒的人，我想残酷的人可能是更好的说法。杀过人，或者参与杀害了他自己的母亲。
He didn't elaborate on it?
他没详细说明吗？
He said this is what had happened, and his dad knew the chief of police-- and this was during prohibition and everything else, and he could always go down and get a gallon of whiskey or whatever it was that he wanted. You know, without any problems. What the relationship was between the chief of police and dad's dad, I have no idea. He didn't elaborate on that. But he had this thing that-- I guess he killed his wife.
他说事情就是这样发生的，他父亲认识警察局长——那是在禁酒令期间和其他一切事情发生的时候，他总能去警察局拿一加仑威士忌或者任何他想要的东西。你知道，没遇到任何问题。警察局长和父亲的父亲之间是什么关系，我不知道。他没详述那个。但他有这件事，就是——我想他杀了他的妻子。
Do you remember what you feel like when he told you that?
你还记得他告诉你这些时你是什么感觉吗？
Well, yeah, I can remember exactly how I felt like. I was surprised. But on the same hand I told my dad-- I said, well you certainly have gone beyond that. And I said to my dad, I said, well it's not always like father like son, is it? And I said, you're a perfect example of that. I said, I can only hope that I can follow in your footsteps.
嗯，是啊，我完全记得我当时的感觉。我很惊讶。但同时也对我的父亲说——我说，你肯定已经超越了那个。我对父亲说，我说，毕竟不是每个儿子都像父亲，不是吗？我说，你就是一个完美的例子。我说，我只能希望我能追随你的脚步。
Did he--
他是否……
He got very emotional at that point in time, and that was pretty much the end of the discussion.
那时候他情绪变得非常激动，讨论基本上就到此为止了。
Did he put any restrictions on you with that information?
他是否对你保密这些信息？
Asked me never to tell anybody about what he had told me. And I gave him my word I wouldn't.
让我永远不要告诉任何人他告诉我的事。我向他保证过我不会。
So you never confided this information to anyone.
所以你从来没有把这些信息透露给任何人。
No, no, no. You're the only one that I've ever told this to. And I guess I can say I hope that it will never go any further than this, but I guess it will. I gave my dad my word that I'd never tell. To me, right now, is that I have broke my word to him.
没有，没有，没有。你是唯一一个我告诉过的人。我猜我可以说我希望它永远不会传得比这更远了，但我想它还是会传出去的。我向我父亲保证过我永远不会说。对我来说，现在就是，我违背了对他许下的诺言。
I called my Uncle John in Colorado. He's actually John B. Keeline III, the middle child. He couldn't believe his brother never told him.
我给科罗拉多的约翰叔叔打了电话。他实际上是约翰·B·基林三世，家里的老二。他不敢相信他哥哥从没告诉过他。
But see, why? I mean this is what this whole goddamn family's made up of, is a bunch of [BLEEP]. Because why didn't my mom and dad keep all that [BLEEP] a secret? Every [BLEEP] thing in this world is a secret. Gosh, I'm not going to tell you guys, because this is a secret. I'm not going to tell you guys, this is a secret. You know, I think that just pure-ass sucks. Excuse the expression, but I think it just sucks. I mean, you know. I mean, that's just like me saying, well I was told everything up front and then I'm going to keep it a secret from my brother and my sister. I think that's [BLEEP], I really and honest to god think it's [BLEEP].
但你看，为什么？我的意思是，这整个该死的家族就是由一堆混蛋组成的。因为为什么我妈妈和爸爸要对所有这些屁事保密？这世上每一件屁事都是秘密。天哪，我不告诉你们，因为这是个秘密。我不告诉你们，这是个秘密。你知道，我觉得这简直烂透了。请原谅我的表达，但我认为这烂透了。我的意思是，我的意思是，就像我说的，好吧，我提前被告知了一切，然后我要对我的哥哥和姐姐保密。我觉得那是胡扯，我真的、上帝诚实地认为那是胡扯。
Uncle John told me that Jim's secret conversation with their father and the secret about my great-grandfather's murder-suicide are just two more items in a long list of family secrets.
约翰叔叔告诉我，吉姆和他们父亲之间的秘密谈话，以及关于我曾祖父谋杀自杀的秘密，只是家族长长秘密清单中的另外两项。
Take the story of Uncle Heine. They were told all their lives he was their mother's uncle. In fact, he was their grandfather, their other grandfather. He used to come over to the house, but everyone who knew was sworn to secrecy.
就拿海涅叔叔的故事来说吧。他们一辈子都被告知他是他们母亲的叔叔。事实上，他是他们的祖父，他们的另一个祖父。他过去常到家里来，但所有知道真相的人都被要求保密。
And how in the world they convinced them that if, in fact, they would ever happen to open their mouth and say-- I mean, those people had to live in ungodly fear. You know? How many times do you think Uncle Heine wanted to say, you know, I'm not your Uncle Heine, I'm your grandfather.
而且他们究竟是怎么让他们相信的——如果他们真的偶尔开口说出来——我的意思是，那些人肯定生活在恐惧之中。你知道吗？你觉得海涅叔叔有多少次想说，你知道，我不是你们的海涅叔叔，我是你们的祖父。
Finally, when their mom was dying, the kids figured it out. And even then, my grandmother wouldn't say a word.
最后，当他们妈妈快要去世时，孩子们自己琢磨出来了。即便如此，我祖母还是一个字都不说。
Jim was the one who came in from the hospital-- it was the day we were going to bring her home and everything. He says, guess who our grandfather was? And I just looked at him, I said Uncle Heine. He said how'd you guess? I said it's the only thing that makes sense. And mom was not going to discuss that. I asked her one time after I found out. I said, you know, tell me about Uncle Heine. "I'm not going to discuss it with you." And that was the end of it. And she was dying, Kevin, I wasn't going to argue the point with her.
吉姆是从医院回来的——那是我们要带她回家的那天，一切都……他说，猜猜我们的祖父是谁？我看着他说海涅叔叔。他说你怎么猜到的？我说这是唯一说得通的事情。妈妈不打算讨论那个。我发现后问过她一次。我说，你知道，告诉我关于海涅叔叔的事。“我不会和你讨论那个的。”讨论就此结束。她当时快要去世了，凯文，我没打算在那点上和她争辩。
That's just the way it was. Secrets were the norm. What nobody fully understands is why their father, John B. Keeline II, went along with it. They all adored him. Not only his kids, but the whole town of Cherokee, where they lived. He was honest and kind, he never even swore. It was his wife, my grandmother, the tiny one with all the jewelry, who insisted on the secrets. So because of her, my mom and uncles all say, the family operated under a strict policy of don't ask don't tell.
事情就是这样。秘密是常态。没人完全理解为什么他们的父亲，约翰·B·基林二世会配合。他们都崇拜他。不仅是他的孩子们，整个切罗基镇的人都崇拜他。他诚实善良，连脏话都不说。是他的妻子，也就是我的祖母，那个戴着珠宝的娇小女人，坚持要保密。所以因为她，我妈妈和叔叔们都说，家族是在严厉的“不问，不说”政策下运作的。
We would have a discussion or whatever, or disagreement, whatever it was in the family-- "We'll talk about it tomorrow." End of discussion. Tomorrow never came.
每当我们进行讨论或发生什么争执，家族里发生了什么事——“我们明天再谈。”讨论结束。明天永远不会来。
You know, every time you turn around, you hear somebody say about eight or six words about something or other and you kind of think, well Jesus, none of that makes sense. But that's all that's ever said.
你知道，每次你一转身，就听到有人说关于某事只说了八个或六个字，你就会有点想，天哪，没一句话说得通。但这已经是一切了。
So they had two grandfathers, and all their lives they never heard the truth about either one-- Uncle Heine or John B. Keeline I. But they were way angrier about Uncle Heine because they saw him all the time. John B. Keeline I was a man they'd never met from a town they didn't live in. But what's strange is, that when I asked them again about the newspaper article, I realized they'd all avoided taking in what he really did. My mom said the killings might have been an accident, and thought she remembered something about cleaning a gun. Jim suggested that the woman he killed might have driven him to it. And then there's John.
所以他们有两个祖父，但一辈子都没听过关于任何一个的真相——无论是海涅叔叔还是约翰·B·基林一世。但他们对海涅叔叔更生气，因为他们经常见到他。约翰·B·基林一世是他们从未见过的人，来自一个他们没住过的城镇。但奇怪的是，当我再问他们关于那篇报纸文章时，我意识到他们都在刻意回避去理解他到底做了什么。我妈妈说那些杀戮可能是意外，还以为自己记得关于清理枪支的事。吉姆暗示他杀的那个女人可能是被逼的。然后还有约翰。
Kevin, I honest to gosh can't even remember what the article was about. I couldn't tell you one absolute word or one thing about what was in any one piece of the article.
凯文，我发誓我甚至不记得文章是关于什么的了。我完全无法告诉你那篇文章里的一字一句，或者其中的任何一件事。
It's as if they'd all had been just as happy to leave it a secret. Here's my mom.
就好像他们都宁愿把它当作一个秘密一样快乐。这就是我妈妈。
I wasn't told these things. There was a reason, evidently, that they didn't want to do it. And I can understand you wanting to find out more, and everything. But on the same hand, I don't want anything said or done that would hurt my dad, or hurt my dad's name. And I feel very strongly about that. My dad was everything to me. I'd just leave it all under the rug before I'd-- basically, I guess, tarnish his name.
这些事没告诉我。显然有原因的，他们不想那样做。我能理解你想找出更多信息，等等。但与此同时，我不想说或做任何会伤害我父亲，或损害我父亲名声的事情。我对此感受非常强烈。我父亲对我来说是一切。我宁愿把这一切都掩盖在桌子底下，也不愿意——我想，玷污他的名声。
In some way, they'd taken on their father's shame about the whole thing and left the history untouched to protect him, and each other, and themselves, against the judgment of outsiders. Exactly the way families are supposed to.
在某种程度上，他们承担了父亲对整件事的耻辱，并让历史保持未触碰状态，以保护他，以及彼此，还有他们自己，免受外人的评价。完全像家人应该做的那样。
I still play the old cylinders on the Edison from time to time. This one called, Then You'll Remember Me. There's a line in the song that goes like this, "There may perhaps, in such a scene some recollection be, of day's that have happy been. Then you'll remember me."
我时不时还会用爱迪生留声机播放那些老唱片。这首叫《然后你会记得我》。歌里有一句是这样的，“也许在这样的场景中，会有一些回忆，关于曾经快乐的日子。然后你会记得我。”
[MUSIC - "Then You'll Remember Me"]
[音乐 - 《然后你会记得我》]
Kevin O'Leary lives in Toronto. Actor Matt Malloy read the 1926 newspaper article for us.
凯文·奥利里住在多伦多。演员马特·马洛伊为我们阅读了1926年的报纸文章。
Coming up, a 12-year-old ruins a day that is 18 years in the making. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一个12岁的孩子毁掉了历经18年才成型的一天。稍后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, Family Legends.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目，家族传奇。
We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Admissions.
我们进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，录取通知书。
This is one of those stories that didn't turn into a family story until one of the kids went to college and started telling this story, and then realized just how unusual her family was. It's partly a story of a prank gone wrong, but it's a prank that the family was building up to for years. Katia Dunn tells the story.
这是一个直到其中一个孩子上大学开始讲这个故事，才意识到她家有多不寻常，才变成家族故事的故事。这在某种程度上是一个恶作剧搞砸了的故事，但这是一个家族多年来一直在为之铺垫的恶作剧。卡蒂亚·邓恩讲述了这个故事。
Megan Curtis can remember her first campus visit as a prospective student. She was eight-years-old. She was the youngest of three girls that on spring break, summer vacation, even some Christmas breaks, when other New Jersey families were going skiing or to the beach, Megan's family was touring college campuses.
梅根·柯蒂斯记得她第一次作为准学生访问校园。那时她才八岁。她是三个女孩中最小的一个，春假、暑假，甚至是圣诞假期，当新泽西州的其他家庭去滑雪或去海滩时，梅根的家庭却在参观大学校园。
NYU, Columbia, U Penn--
纽约大学、哥伦比亚大学、宾夕法尼亚大学……
You can hear in her voice how much she enjoyed those visits. Megan figures that they visited 40 or 50 schools before they even began filling out their applications.
你能从她的声音中听出她有多么享受那些参观。梅根估计他们甚至在开始填写申请表之前就参观了40或50所学校。
I was intentionally brought along on all these visits because, you know, in 10 years I would be going to college too. So it was important for me to have some sort of impression of these places.
我之所以被特意带去所有这些参观，是因为，你知道，十年后我也会上大学。所以对我来说，对这些地方有一些印象很重要。
And were you excited at all about college?
那你对上大学感到兴奋吗？
No, I hated going on them. It was boring, it was really boring.
不，我讨厌去那些地方。很无聊，真的非常无聊。
It was Megan's mom who insisted on the visits. She was obsessed with finding the perfect school for each of her daughters. She read the college guide so often that their bindings wore out.
是梅根的妈妈坚持要进行这些参观的。她痴迷于为她的每个女儿寻找完美的学校。她阅读大学指南的频率高到书脊都磨损了。
Not satisfied with the book's rating systems, she posted charts on the refrigerator with rankings of her own. She hung up a map of the United States and traced a pizza pan on it. Colleges inside the circle were OK to apply to. Colleges outside the circle were too far from home.
不满足于书中的评价系统，她在冰箱上贴了她自己制定的排名表。她在上面挂了一张美国地图，并用披萨盘在上面画了个圈。圈内的大学可以申请。圈外的大学离家太远。
I remember going, searching high and low to find Wite-Out strips that were the same color as all of the applications. So, like, let's say James Madison had manila paper-- you know, she really went all over the state of New Jersey looking for the exact right color of manila Wite-Out strips. And she found them.
我记得去搜索到处寻找那种和所有申请表颜色一样的修正液带。所以，比如，假设詹姆斯麦迪逊大学有马尼拉纸——你知道，她真的跑遍了新泽西州寻找颜色完全正确的马尼拉修正液带。然后她找到了。
It wasn't enough, said her mother, to fill out an application. When Megan's older sister, Amanda, started applying to colleges, she needed a way to stand out. So her mother commissioned the owner of the local video store to make a film about Amanda's field hockey career. It was set to Eye Of The Tiger. Megan remembers it clearly.
她说，填好申请表是不够的。当梅根的姐姐阿曼达开始申请大学时，她需要一种脱颖而出的方式。所以她母亲委托当地录像店的老板制作了一部关于阿曼达曲棍球生涯的电影。配乐是《虎眼》。梅根记得很清楚。
The video starts off with Mandy giving this really awkward monologue.
视频开头是曼迪进行了一段非常尴尬的独白。
Hi, my name is Mandy Curtis. I'm the captain of this year's varsity field hockey team at Middletown High School South.
嗨，我叫曼迪·柯蒂斯。我是米德尔敦高中南校今年校队曲棍球队的队长。
Very clearly, my mother scripted for her. That sort of runs through every single accomplishment that she had ever made in her field hockey career, going all the way back to the seventh grade.
很明显，是我妈妈为她写的剧本。那段话贯穿了她曲棍球生涯中所有的成就，一直追溯到七年级。
And eighth grade, I was the captain of my eighth grade team, and selected as an all-star.
还有八年级，我是八年级校队的队长，并入选了全明星赛。
She wouldn't get in if she left any of these things out.
如果她遗漏了这些，她就不会被录取。
On JV, I dressed for a few varsity games for the state championships, and saw some time.
在二队，我参加了几场州冠军赛的校队比赛，也获得了一些出场时间。
I do remember thinking it was pretty cool that I had a video.
我确实记得觉得拥有一段关于自己的视频很酷。
And here's Amanda.
这就是阿曼达。
It was filmed in front of our house and it was such a suburb sort of scene. And I'm sure it did nothing to help me. If anything, it made me look probably younger and more immature and not ready to go to college. But I thought it was pretty good. I still do.
它是在我们家门口拍的，那场景真是太郊区了。我敢肯定这对我的申请毫无帮助。如果有的话，它可能让我看起来更年轻、更不成熟，还没有做好上大学的准备。但我当时觉得它很棒。现在我也这么认为。
To understand what happened next, you have to consider that, by now, 12-year-old Megan was feeling pretty sorry for herself. She was miserable. Her mom's obsession with college put everyone in the house on edge. And with everybody worrying about her sister's application, nobody was paying any attention to Megan. All the family cared about was the letter they knew would soon arrive from the Davidson College admissions office, saying whether Amanda had been admitted to her first choice school. And if Megan thought the application part of the process had been agonizing-- well, this was worse.
要理解接下来发生的事情，你必须考虑到，到那时，12岁的梅根感到自己很可怜。她很难过。她妈妈对大学的痴迷让家里每个人都处于紧张状态。每个人都在为她姐姐的申请担心，没人注意梅根。全家关心的只有他们知道很快就会从戴维森学院招生办寄来的信，告知阿曼达是否被她的第一志愿学校录取。如果梅根认为申请过程的那部分已经够折磨人了——嗯，这更糟。
I couldn't take the waiting anymore. You know, I was every day checking the mailbox. It wasn't there, It wasn't there, it wasn't there.
我再也受不了等待了。你知道，我每天都在查看邮箱。没有，没在里面，没在里面。
So I decided that it was time to end the waiting and write my own acceptance letter for Amanda. And so I did that.
所以我决定是时候结束等待，亲自为阿曼达写一封录取通知信了。于是我做了。
I found the dean of the admissions' name, and the address of the admissions office. And I cut out the heading, their letterhead. So I sat down and I wrote this letter. Actually, I have it here.
我找到了招生办主任的名字和地址。我剪下了他们的标题，他们的信笺抬头。所以我坐下来写了这封信。实际上，我有它在这里。
"Dear Amanda, it is with great pleasures that we write to inform you of your acceptance to Davidson College, class of 1996. With a record number of applications this year, it was not easy to get in this year. But after reading your inspiring application, we knew you would be an admirable addition to this institution's cast of stars."
“亲爱的阿曼达，我们怀着巨大的喜悦通知你，你已被戴维森学院1996届录取。今年申请人数创纪录，录取并不容易。但在阅读了你鼓舞人心的申请后，我们知道你将成为本校明星阵容中令人钦佩的一员。”
The letter was very clearly written by an eleven-year-old.
这封信很明显是由一个11岁的孩子写的。
"We were especially impressed with your amazing sports talent.
“我们对你惊人的运动天赋印象深刻。”
I know that this must be a very inspiring time for you but is also very important to concentrate on the first tuition deposit. We need it pretty soon. Please make sure to send the check to our admissions office right after this letter arrives at your house.
我知道这对你来说一定是一个非常激动人心的时刻，但集中精力支付第一笔学费押金也非常重要。我们需要尽快收到它。请确保在这封信寄到你家后立即把支票寄到我们的招生办公室。
We hope you are as happy as we are that you got in here.
我们希望你和我们一样高兴你能被录取。
Sincerely, Nancy J. Cable, Dean of Admission."
真诚的，南希·J·凯布尔，招生主任。”
I remember thinking, God, this is great. This is so good, this is my best work. I really should try to send it to her.
我记得当时想，天哪，这太棒了。这太好了，这是我的巅峰之作。我真的应该试着寄给她。
I somehow, I think, just wanted her to feel like she had gotten in. Because she so badly wanted to get in. And more than that, my mother so badly wanted her to get in. And I think, in some ways, it was probably for my own benefit, too. I wanted to be a part of this whole thing, too.
我不知怎么地，我想，只是想让她感觉到她被录取了。因为她太渴望被录取了。而且不仅如此，我妈妈太渴望她被录取了。我想，在某种程度上，这可能也是为了我自己的利益。我也想参与到这一切中来。
Megan's dad ran a business out of their house, which made finding the FedEx envelope and filling it out no problem.
梅根的爸爸在家经营一家生意，这使得找个联邦快递信封并填好它完全没问题。
I put the envelope in the screen door, rang the doorbell, bolted away, and then sort of waited around a little while so I could casually make my way back into the house, coming through the garage door entrance so that nobody would suspect me.
我把信封放进纱门，按了门铃，跑开了，然后在那附近等了一小会儿，这样我就可以随意地回到家里，通过车库门入口走进去，这样没人会怀疑我。
And the moment I walked into the house I knew that I had made a really, really bad decision.
而我走进家门的那一刻，我就知道我做了一个非常、非常糟糕的决定。
Amanda was still in bed when the letter arrived.
那封信寄到时，阿曼达还在睡觉。
The doorbell rings, and my mom went to get it. I'm surprised she didn't fall down the stairs because she was running up frantically to me. And, you know, just flew open my door, was like "It's here! It's here!" And woke me up, literally, like that. And I remember then just sitting on my bed opening it. And definitely very nervous, and of course my mom is hovering over me. And at that point I think my dad had come in.
门铃响了，我妈去开门。我很惊讶她没摔下楼，因为她疯狂地跑过来。而且，你知道，简直是冲进了我的房间，就像“它到了！它到了！”然后直接把我叫醒了。我记得当时我就坐在床上打开它。非常紧张，当然我妈在那儿盘旋。而且那时候我想我爸爸也进来了。
So I open the letter and I remember reading it. And, oh my gosh, what relief. Like, utter emotional relief. Thank god, I got in. And so there's this great elation, just such excitement and happiness. And I don't even think I read the whole letter, actually, at that point. Because I was just like, you know, just a real sigh. And my mom, of course, very thrilled and hugging me.
所以我打开信，我记得读了它。天哪，多么解脱。就像，彻底的情感上的释放。谢天谢地，我被录取了。所以我感到非常狂喜，那么激动和快乐。而且我甚至不觉得我读了整封信，实际上，在那个时候。因为我就像，你知道，真的长吁了一口气。而我妈，当然，非常激动并拥抱我。
And then I see the little figure of my sister, Meg, coming up the top of the steps. And I see her in the doorway looking very sort of meek.
然后我看到了我妹妹梅格的身影，从楼梯顶端走过来。我看到她站在门口，看起来很温顺的样子。
I was completely terrified. I decided that the only solution was to come clean now. I couldn't take the immense guilt. So I went upstairs and I said, feeling like I needed to somehow make light of it, somehow draw their attention to how funny this was, came out and said, it was me, I did it. You know, wacky smile and jazz hands.
我彻底吓坏了。我决定唯一的解决办法就是现在就坦白。我受不了那巨大的内疚感。所以我走上楼说，觉得我需要以某种方式让它显得轻松一点，以某种方式引起他们的注意，告诉他们这有多好笑，出来说道，是我，我做的。你知道，古怪的笑容和爵士手势。
As you can imagine, this didn't fly. The way her mom saw it, Megan had taken one of the biggest days of their lives, the day Amanda would get into college, and turned it into a joke.
你可以想象，这没管用。在她妈妈看来，梅根把他们一生中最大的日子之一，阿曼达考上大学的日子，变成了一个笑话。
My mom thought that I had just committed the most egregious sin that one could commit. How sick are you that this would even enter into your mind? This is not something that a normal person would do.
我妈觉得我犯下了一个人能犯下的最令人震惊的罪。你的思想怎么能生病到这种地步，这甚至会进入你的脑海？这不是正常人会做的事情。
Here's Amanda.
这是阿曼达。
My mom would say, how could you be so evil, how could you be so terrible, how could you hate your sister so much? Things even like, you're not part of our family, where did you come from, that kind of abuse. That definitely pounded into Meg's head that what she had done was really, really, really wrong.
我妈会说，你怎么能这么邪恶，你怎么能这么糟糕，你怎么能这么恨你妹妹？甚至像，你不是我们家的人，你从哪儿冒出来的，那种虐待。那确实敲进了梅格的脑袋，让她觉得她所做的事情真的、真的、真的错了。
I know Meg went into her room, and to be honest, I don't think she really came out of her room. You know, I mean, metaphorically speaking. I think that was kind of a turning point for Meg that she really started to sort of shut herself off from a lot of us.
我知道梅格回到了她的房间，老实说，我不觉得她真的从房间里出来过。你知道，我是说，比喻意义上。我觉得那是梅格的一个转折点，她真的开始试图把自己从我们很多人中封闭起来。
I felt awful about myself afterwards. I had this serious guilt, and I cried, and I just went into this very serious depression. I started wondering, maybe there is something wrong with me. Why did I do this?
事后我对自己感觉糟糕透了。我有严重的内疚感，我哭了，我陷入了非常严重的抑郁。我开始怀疑，也许我有什么毛病。我为什么要这么做？
About a week after Megan's letter arrived at the door, Amanda got another acceptance letter from Davidson College. This time, it was real.
在梅根的信寄到门口大约一周后，阿曼达收到了戴维森学院的另一封录取通知信。这一次，它是真的。
Megan was off the hook as far as her sister goes, but the situation with her mom was a little more complicated. Actually, it still is. Even today, way after Megan has graduated from Vassar College, she still gets upset talking about all this.
就她姐姐而言，梅根脱离了困境，但她和她妈妈的情况有点复杂。实际上，直到今天还是。即使是现在，在梅根从瓦萨尔学院毕业很久之后，她谈起这一切时仍然会感到心烦。
And when I ask Megan if I can interview her mom for the story, she said she didn't think her mom would want to talk about it much. Megan was sure her mom was still just as mad about the letter as she had been years ago. Which is why I was so surprised when her mother told me how she remembered it.
当我问梅根我能否采访她妈妈来讲述这个故事时，她说她觉得她妈妈不会想多谈论这件事。梅根确定她妈妈仍然像几年前一样生这个信的气。这就是为什么当她母亲告诉我她是如何记住这件事时，我感到如此惊讶。
I think of this as a funny time. I don't think of this little prank of hers as being-- now, looking back on it, quite so evil as I did then. It was funny, it is funny, it was funny.
我觉得这是一段有趣的时光。我不觉得她这个小恶作剧是——现在回想起来，像当时那么邪恶。它很有趣，它是很有趣的，它当时就很有趣。
When you told Megan that she had done a horrible thing, did you feel bad about it, when you told her that? Do you feel bad about it now?
当你告诉梅根她做了一件可怕的事情时，你觉得坏吗，当你告诉她的时候？你现在觉得坏吗？
I probably was over the top. I probably reacted more strongly than I would have, in retrospect. I'm sure I overreacted.
我可能太过分了。回顾起来，我的反应可能比我本应该有的反应更强烈。我敢肯定我反应过度了。
When I told Megan what her mom said, she was floored.
当我告诉梅根她妈妈说的话时，她惊呆了。
OK, that's kind of shocking that she said that. I have always had the sense that she really felt like this was still a really bad thing to do. And it wasn't funny in any way.
好吧，她说了那样的话真是令人震惊。我一直觉得她真的觉得这仍然是一件非常糟糕的事情。而且它一点也不好笑。
So what do you make of this?
那你怎么看待这件事？
I don't know. I mean, I feel like she's making it up.
我不知道。我的意思是，我觉得她在编造。
So you think she's lying?
所以你认为她在撒谎？
Yeah, I think she's lying. She didn't think it was funny, that's ridiculous.
是啊，我认为她在撒谎。她不觉得这很有趣，那太荒谬了。
So it sounds like you still have some resentment.
所以听起来你仍然有一些怨恨。
[LAUGHS] Well, you know, I mean, I guess I shouldn't if this is the way she really feels. And I think you have to come to a point where you stop holding grudges against your parents.
[笑声] 嗯，你知道，我是说，我想如果这是她真实的感觉，我就不应该那样了。而且我觉得你必须走到一个不再对父母怀恨在心的地步。
Megan's mom explains her behavior this way. Back when she was choosing a college, she didn't look around for schools, nobody helped her. She ended up choosing the school closest to the cousin's house where she would be eating Thanksgiving dinner. She always regretted it, she says, and she wanted her kids to have something different.
梅根多年来一直讲述那个伪造信件的故事。对她来说，寓意是这样的——看看我妈妈在大学录取这些事上表现得多么疯狂。
I thought I was doing a great thing for my family. I was doing for my children what I had wished that my parents had done for me. I think they recognize the lengths that I went to get them to heights that I thought they could achieve.
最近，她妈妈也开始讲这个故事了。她得出的结论和她女儿一样。
And they all got into excellent colleges and they all have done wonderful things that I'm proud of and that they're proud of. Whether or not they think my part in it was an important part, I'm not sure. I wonder. I wonder if they'll look back and say, wow, look at what mom did for us. Maybe they won't, I don't know.
故事是关于我们表现得多么过分，以及一个小女孩如何让我们回归现实。我想这就是它的意义所在。并不是说我们不会再以同样的方式做一次。因为我觉得基本上我们就是这样的人，即使我们看到了自己方式中的错误，那也不意味着我们未必会重复它们。我已经开始考虑我的孙女可能去哪里上大学了。我有一个刚出生的孙女。
Megan's been telling the fake letter story for years. And for her, the moral is this-- look how crazy my mom acted with this college admissions stuff.
[笑声]
Recently, her mom started telling the story, too. And she draws the same conclusion as her daughter.
我们已经开始用里面的钱存钱罐了，而且谈论——她才三个月大。
The story was about how over the top we were and how it took a little girl to bring us down to reality. I think that's what it's about. Not to say that we wouldn't do it the same way again. Because I think basically we are who we are and even though we see the error of our ways, that doesn't mean we won't necessarily repeat them. I'm already thinking of where my granddaughter might go to college. I have a brand new granddaughter.
瓦萨尔学院，随时期待2022届的一段视频。
[LAUGHS]
卡蒂亚·邓恩。她的节目今天由莎拉·凯尼格和我制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、温迪·多尔、简·费尔特斯和丽莎·波拉克。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和威尔·雷歇尔提供了制作帮助。今天特别感谢[? Fuan ?] 威廉姆斯和德米特里[? Schube ?]。
We've already started the piggy bank with the money in it, and talking-- she's three months old.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们的节目或购买CD。或者，你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。
Vassar College, expect a video for the class of 2022 any day.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际台发行。
Katia Dunn. Her program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Will Reichel. Special thanks today to [? Fuan ?] Williams and Dmitri [? Schube ?].
[资助信用]
Our web site, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs absolutely free or buy CDs of them. Or, you know, you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。你知道，人们总是问我，他到底是什么样的人？我认为他们终于找到了一种方法来传达这一点。
This American Life is distrubted by Public Radio International.
想象一个娇小的、苍老的、白人老太太，有着T先生的脾气和时尚感，你大概就能明白我的意思了。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, people ask me all the time, what's he really like? and I think they have finally figured out a way to get it across.
PRI，公共广播国际台。
Imagine a tiny, little, white lady, with the temper and fashion sense of Mr. T, and you get the idea.
想象一下一位娇小玲珑的白人女士，却有着T先生那样的脾气和时尚品味，你大概就能明白我的意思了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。